bonjour 10000 m car au cœur du parc
d'affaires du val-sint-quentin à voisin
lebretonneux c'est le nouveau siège de
ropecar France installé auparavant
pendant plus de 30 ans à Montini 200
salariés ont pris leur quartier depuis 6
mois l'esprit d'avoir un parc
d'activités avec des espaces verts et
pour nous un changement qui est
bénéfique par rapport à là où nous
étions auparavant avoir son siège dans
les ivelines c'est être au plus proche
des constructeurs automobiles notamment
Renault et Peugeot Citroën mais aussi de
ses clients c'est économique qui se
développe donc nous avons aussi un
certain nombre de clientèle clients soit
PME PMI ou grand compte des clients
àaires qui sont aussi sur le Passin
économique qui se développe une enseigne
de taille pour le promoteur Codic
gestionnaire de ce parc d'affaires le
valsint-quentin a commencé ses travaux
en 2002 en mettant l'accent sur les
normes environnementales nous avons
commencé à acquérir les premiers biens
en 2000 et nous avons commencé à
construire les trois premiers bâtiments
en 2002 sans financement bancaire
puisque personne ne croya en cette
aventure puisque que le concept du parc
est un peu un parc à anglo-saxon avec
notamment beaucoup de parkings en
sous-sol tous les bâtiments de cette
phase répondent à la RT 2012 donc nous
sommes assez loin en NME environnemental
les bâtiments ont tous une signature
Bram vigout donc encore des normes qui
sont assez élevées en Europe en tout 13
bâtiments composeront à terme le
valsint-quentin sont déjà installés
Adidas ribook yasaki Siemens ou encore
bentler Automotive livraison des
derniers bâtiments prévus en